miles feiner is an atheist from New York
City who runs a podcast to preach his
messages he believes that everything in
life happens for a reason and that there
is no Supernatural Force governing it
the podcasts have made him somewhat
popular Among The Atheist Community but
at the same time he has also gained some
haters despite this miles is completely
carefree and doesn't miss an opportunity
to detest God every chance he gets he
usually invites religious guests in his
podcast and makes fun of their beliefs
and ideologies dude's irregular Bill Nye
but one day something very strange
happens as miles is walking home he gets
a friend request on Facebook from an
account named God miles obviously thinks
someone is messing around with him so he
simply declines the request and
continues on his way however the request
keeps popping up again and again despite
miles rejecting it every single time
surprisingly the profile picture is a
small Cloud which is the same exact one
that miles can see from his doorstep fed
up with the continuous notifications he
finally accepts the request and as soon
as he does so God God sends him a
friend's suggestion of someone named
John Dove just then a guy bumps into him
and profusely starts apologizing miles
stares at him closely and realizes that
the person is none other than John Dove
the same guy who God has suggested to
add on Facebook thinking that someone is
pranking him miles decides to follow Jon
and confront him soon he reaches the
subway where a lot of passengers are
present the train is about to arrive and
seeing Jon very anxious miles realizes
that he is about to commit the
unthinkable fortunately before anything
bad can happen miles pulls him and saves
his life Jon who now seems to have
turned to Corner thanks miles for
changing his perception and departs that
night a completely confused miles
wonders about why someone would prank
him like this he searches John Dove on
Facebook but doesn't find much
information on him he then goes through
God's account and finds that he or she
likes nature right then God sends him
another friend suggestion a beautiful
girl named Cara Bloom later at midnight
mile suddenly wakes up to loud music
playing in his room it turns out that
someone is hacked into his computer and
deleted his important presentations
about atheism moreover the music speaker
thermostat lights and other equipment in
the house have also been tampered with
one thing is clear someone hates miles
following this we are introduced to Kara
Bloom an aspiring journalist who works
at a big firm she used to be the top
performer there but for some weeks her
performance has been very lackluster
this has landed her in hot water and now
her boss is warned her to submit a good
article soon or else she will be fired
shortly after an angry miles barges into
her office and confronts her for
whatever Shenanigans she and her friends
are up to he also tells her to stop
hacking into his computer and messing
around with his stuff however Cara who
is clearly angry by the sudden intrusion
doesn't understand what he is saying
miles shows her his phone and explains
the whole ordeal then the two talk for a
while and come to a conclusion that
someone is messing with both of them
miles appears to be very worried by the
pranks but surprisingly Cara finds the
story interesting and decides to write
an article about it she also promises to
help find the culprit and as a result
miles agrees to work together that
evening the two approach miles's hacker
friend Rakesh and request him to find
the IP address of the Facebook account
God Rakesh doesn't do favors for his
male friends but when he sees the
beautiful Cara he gets straight to work
hackers can be simps too however after
some digging he learns that the god
account is protected by a firewall never
seen before only a billionaire or an
ultra genius is capable of operating
such firewalls despite this Rakesh uses
all his knowledge works all night and
finally finds the location God is in
Jersey guy must love baseball and
boardwalks wasting no time miles and
Cara go to the sub location it turns out
to be a gloomy looking house that has
been put up on sale the duo scans every
room but finds nothing except for a
painting of God on the wall this
indicates that whosoever is behind the
pranks was expecting miles to arrive in
the next scene Kara and Miles return to
the latter's home where Rakesh and his
girlfriend are also present surprisingly
my his computer is operating on its own
as if someone has again hacked it soon
it stops at one of miles's family
pictures and when Kara sees it she
becomes upset and walks away miles and
Rakesh are confused by why she left and
after some thinking they realized that
Kara knows someone from the picture the
picture is from 20 years ago when
miles's mother was at the hospital
battling cancer the two Unknown People
from the picture are doctors but miles
doesn't know their names hence he goes
to the only person who might have the
answers his father David ironically
David is a priest who gives regular
speeches about God miles approaches him
and the two have a brief argument over
their contrasting differences
nonetheless he sets his rivalry aside
and shows the picture David recognizes
the female doctor as Susan Bloom hearing
this miles realizes that the woman in
the picture is none other than Kara's
mother at night he meets Cara and learns
that she's been estranged from her
mother for the last 22 years Susan
suddenly laughed and never came back
that's why Cara became emotional when
she saw her mother's picture after so
long with this it finally Dawns on Miles
that everything is connected the person
named God actually sent him to help
Carol reunite with her mom the following
day he manages to track Susan down and
encourages Kara to approach and talk to
her the latter is pretty nervous but
nonetheless she proceeds with it Susan
immediately recognizes her estranged
daughter and appears to feel guilty for
leaving her however the very next second
her other daughter arrives indicating
that she has commenced a new life here
this enrages Kara and she starts running
ignoring miles's pleas for her to stop
unfortunately she ends up getting hit
and knocked out by a car miles quickly
arrives at the scene but Kara seems to
be unconscious she is not breathing it
appears as if she has met her untimely
demise but just then a so-called doctor
steps out of a nearby car he is none
other than John Dove the guy miles saved
earlier at the subway John immediately
administers CPR and resuscitates Kara
hence saving her life miles is left in
utter disbelief at how everyone is
connected to one another the next
morning at the hospital Cara appears to
have recovered from the shock in the
meantime her estranged mother Susan
visits her and apologizes for leaving
her 22 years ago she then reveals that
she never came back because of her
abusive husband she did see her daughter
a few times at school but never had the
courage to approach her hearing all this
Kara tears up and eventually forgives
her mother in this way the friend
suggestions from God saved the lives of
two different people Cara and John Dove
Kara's probably still a crappy writer
though a few days passed by and Miles
has started to move on from the bizarre
incidents that brought him closer to
some unknown people he has also resumed
his daily podcast where he still
preaches about atheism one day a big
company approaches him and offers to
take his podcast to the next level they
offer him a six-figure contract which
will see him becoming rich overnight
miles is ecstatic with the offer but the
same day God sends him another friend
suggestion on Facebook this time it's a
woman named Katie Brooks however miles
declines it and goes to meet his new as
the two talk about ways to improve the
podcast miles gets a notification on his
phone God has changed his profile
picture previously it was a cloud on a
sunny day but now it's a cloud on a
sunny day with a rainbow over it just
kidding now it's a picture of scary
lightning at the same time the weather
changes and it starts thundering outside
with this miles realizes that God
doesn't want him to continue with the
podcasts hence on the advice of his best
friend rakash he decides to approach the
new friend suggestion Katie Brooks
Rakesh also helps him find her work
address and after a while both miles and
Kara head there Katie appears to work at
a restaurant in a busy locality which
has a lot of people coming in and out
however she is always late which often
causes a heated confrontation with her
boss even today Katie arrives late at
work and mentions that she had to take
care of her sick son however her boss is
having none of it he berates her in
front of all the customers and calls her
a good for nothing woman miles who is
hearing all this feels that Katie is
being wrongly treated and comes to her
support he tells the rude boss that he
shouldn't be talking to a woman that way
and demands that he give her an apology
the boss says sorry but also says you're
fired in This Way Miles ends up getting
Katie fired from her job later he
catches up with Rakesh and requests him
to find Katie's home address so that he
can apologize to her nothing says sorry
like straight up stalking Rakesh is
skeptical about giving up other people's
personal addresses but when his best
friend keeps on insisting that it's for
her good he agrees shortly after miles
reaches Katie's apartment and formally
apologizes he then proceeds to show her
some vacancies which apparently pay well
and they're located nearby however Katie
who is terrified that a random guy has
found her address asks him to go away
miles explains that he's only doing this
for her good but Katie doesn't listen to
any of it after a dejected miles leaves
Katie gets a call from her friend
informing her that a vacancy for the
position of a waitress has just opened
but in order to apply she has to come
right away or else the position will be
occupied by someone else Katie then asks
for at least one day as she can't leave
her son alone but the friend says it's
now or never and hang things up this is
when Katie realizes that she has someone
who can help she runs downstairs stops
miles and tells him that there is
actually one thing he can do for her
please stalk her babysit my son in the
next scene Katie her son Nate and Miles
walked to the restaurant where the
interview is supposedly taking place
along the way Katie reveals that her
husband left them six years ago for
another woman she also mentions that her
son is mute and autistic this is the
reason why she can't leave him alone and
was always late for work hence she wants
miles to look after him while she's
giving her interview miles takes this as
the perfect opportunity to make up for
his earlier mistake and agrees
immediately later they reach the
restaurant and Katie leaves her son in
the care of miles before departing for
the interview 30 minutes passed by and
when she doesn't return miles gets bored
and tries to strike up a conversation
with the little boy he talks about
sports and politics but as expected Nate
cannot hear any of it he simply sits
there silently but as he is staring at
the window he notices a guy with a
guitar and becomes intrigued Nate gets
up from his seat and leaves the
restaurant prompting miles to chase
after him soon they reach a music shop
where Nate expresses his desire to learn
the piano miles knows how to play so he
starts teaching the boy some notes soon
he gets into the groove and plays a
melodious song Meanwhile at the
restaurant Katie finishes her interview
only to find that her son and the
stranger are missing at the same time
Cara also comes looking for miles and
together the two ladies start looking
for the boys fortunately they find the
music shop where Nate and Miles are
enjoying the piano the little boy can
even be seen smiling something which he
hasn't done in years however despite the
clear image that her son is Happy Katie
is angry that Miles didn't wait for her
at the restaurant hence she storms off
with her son miles is left confused as
to what he did wrong hence he makes up
his mind to stop helping Katie as no
matter how hard he tries he just keeps
making her angry since when is
kidnapping a faux pas the following day
Cara goes to meet Katie and check if she
is doing all right only to find out that
little Nate has run away the boy
apparently wandered off a few hours ago
without any message soon miles also
arrives at the scene and starts looking
for Nate along with the others Katie is
especially worried because her son has
never ventured out alone he can't speak
can't read and doesn't even show any
emotion hearing this Smiles mentions
that Nate does show emotions referring
to the time that they were playing piano
he then hypothesizes that Nate might
have gone to the same music shop because
music is the only thing that brings him
happiness the Assumption turns out to be
correct as when miles Katie and Cara
reach the music shop and talk with the
owner they learned that a certain boy
matching Nate's description had come to
the shop about 30 minutes ago however he
soon laughed when the shop was closed if
the shop was closed how did they talk to
the owner the trio deduces that Nate
hasn't gone too far and starts searching
all the nearby music shops and right
then miles notices a poster of an
orchestra event that is happening nearby
the group Rush is there and this time
they find the little boy surprisingly he
is playing Beautiful Boy by John Lennon
this is the same song his mother sings
for him before sleeping despite being
non-verbal the boys picked up the tune
and it seems is like he has finally
found his passion his father may have
left him at a young age but John Lennon
never did oh I guess Nate doesn't know
about Yoko Ono at last miles finally
realizes that God is indeed real and
stops talking about Atheism in his
podcasts he even cancels his six-figure
contract with the large company with the
days passing by Miles gets several
friend suggestions on Facebook by God
and he helps each of them overcome their
problems however he is curious to know
what God actually looks like one day his
chance finally comes through a book he
gets to know that God is living in the
Himalayas miles immediately travels to
Nepal and climbs through the dangerous
mountains after days of wandering around
a little monk approaches him and says
follow me she's been waiting for you if
this story taught me anything it's that
God spends too much time on social media
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching